In June 2021, the Office of the Director of
National Intelligence issued its long-awaited
report on unidentified aerial phenomena. Pollsters
have been asking Americans about UFOs since the
early 1970s and the public has long been skeptical
about what the government knows about them.
A quarter century ago, 71% told Gallup the
government knew more than it was telling us.
This summer, before the government's report cameout,
65% echoed that sentiment in an Economist/YouGov poll.
11% said the government hadtold the public
everything it knows and 24% weren't sure.
The government found no evidence that the
aerial phenomena seen in recent years were alien
spacecraft, but they couldn't explain what is going
on up in the atmosphere. In a Gallup question
asked after the report came out, 41% said that
they believe some UFOs have been extraterrestrial
spacecraft, while 50% said all sightings could be
explained by human activity or natural phenomena.
It's clear that the government's report hasn't
dampened public interest in UFOs.
Have you ever seen a UFO? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let usknow what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
andsubscribe for more research and videos from AEI.